i'm joined by brian blessed brian we
were hoping to have a very sort of
euphoric chat i guess indeed i i want to
try to have brian blessed on it there
she's feeling a bit ill at the moment
of course i've come from home where i
live about half an hour away from here
and i'm married to hildegard neil the
actress
and she
she's very ill my wife she's had cancer
she then she's had pneumonia got over
there
and now permanent disease and she's
having exactly what the queen's got so
oh god it does make you mad sometimes
you sometimes wish you were a god and
you could put it all right but i i i'm
very sorry to hear about your wife uh i
but she's going to be all right is it
going to be all right she'll be fine she
she's the one who played cleopatra to
charlton henson and many years that
beautiful woman and she's cheerful and
lovely about it but please send her our
very best well i'm not very good at
handling illness because i'm always a
keep fit guy and this that the other i i
just like to say that um
years ago keeping the acting thing up
that peter o'toole uh
at his wildest moments
uh he said to me uh you know the queen
i've met her several times
she's
got something special
he never praised anybody she was very
special as you say amazing quality brian
oh yes she's
she's very different
she has what makes her special because i
agree and she's obviously now the
longest reigning monarch we've had
longest reigning monarch the world has
seen she's also now the oldest monarch
that we've had she's 96. um obviously we
probably won't have any other jubilees
for this this queen but what a
remarkable reign that she's i'll give
you an instance i mean of course i'm 85
she's 95. i mean i'm young at 85.
and of course i saw her father i'm a war
baby yeah and i lived in gold fort
between don gaster and barnsley and said
that after the war along came george vi
he came into guelph i'm waving a little
flag
and he gave me got out of his car and
gave me a sixpence really
yes and he looked so pale i thought god
he looks so delicate
and pale uh uh you know and and so
it's astonishing that uh i i met her her
father yes i'd i'd better say jump ahead
to give you an idea of her she
frequently came to see cats the musical
and i was old deuteronomy
i knocked on the door i had a gay
dresser it was covered in cancer poor
son you know pressing all the lumps on
his body come on live live live and pour
out the tea uh is there any way to treat
him he looks so dreadful and the queen
was coming
she and she's coming down the court
without the we'd have the lou painter
with the corridors painted and she could
have tea with me and my lovely gay
dresser very old always having a heart
attack oh god she's coming
she's coming down the corridor i said
it's all right she's all right mom
we painted the toilet we've done this oh
thank you so much where is it oh yeah
and right i think i'll be back in a
second and she came back and i said he's
not very well and he's terrified about
meeting you oh
don't worry
i pour out the tea
and coffee and biscuits how many sugars
do you take yeah you just relax and she
took over the whole thing made him feel
happy and she made tea for us made cakes
for us cut them up how am i amazing and
when you when you're one-on-one with the
queen brian what's she like
well i mean she finds me very naughty
and we all do i mean she oh you know
i mean when she gave me the ob
what did she say
what did the queen say and she
i mean she said you know
she said mr blessed you know
um
wisdom of this
uh
i
i do believe that people have told me
that you imitate me i said no i don't
she said you're such a liar
the queen called you a liar
and so
that
and i then talked about us about her son
charles i work with i'm an ambassador
for him yes saving animals all over the
world he's terrific the intimidator of
bloody marvelous yes people a a
tremendous he's a green green green
green green we need him you didn't she
didn't you actually try and buy camilla
from him well i've always had well let
me i'm going to play you a damning clip
where you literally tell the future
queen console that you tried to buy here
watch this
and she came backstage and it was
christmas and i there i was made father
christmas i was naked underneath my
costume and so forth and she came and
sat on my knee and she was darling
darling she said to uh a husband sat on
your knee yes and she said at at the the
theater where we were doing it they had
that dreary lane not really the other
one palladium and she sat on my knee and
said and she darling darling she picked
up the phone to challenge darling that
i'm here darling i'm with father
christmas which is brian blessed and i
do believe he's not got any underwear on
and i'm sat on his knee and he wants to
buy me
can you work out a prize he said hello
brian he said no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no about it oh
she's worthless nothing you can have for
nothing
oh thank you he says i can have you for
nothing oh good i'm yours
and so i've always had this uh wild
relationship as i said working with him
and and doing and what does she mean
brian what does she mean to this country
and what did today mean about about
britain yeah i mean when you watch the
the pomp and the pageant stream this
little old lady commanding the attention
of the entire world what does it say
about her
and the country can you give me another
two minutes yes i want to emphasize what
royalty is now i was in henry the fifth
with ken browner and the henry v
was then uh
uh
it was then produced in japan and there
was a big premier with the entire power
of japan government attending the first
night and pending the fifth ken vanessa
v with me as a duke of exeter and i was
going to open this whole thing with
princess sam now princess anne i'm a war
baby
i'm going into you know teljo i'm going
into uh
uh you know the japanese powerhouse
there's we arrive there we watch the
film and with princess anne and then she
and i have to go and meet the entire
length and breadth
of all these ambassadors and there and
there also was his highness
the emperor and the empress there the
power of japan i'm gonna call my son
and anne really i did flirt with and she
loves it all the time and she was saying
i just said when are we going to get mad
no stopping by
you can marry me any time you watch is
there any member of the royal family you
haven't tried it on with brian very very
expensive and
i don't know who they are
i've got to introduce you and she said
oh we'll ask them who this this was the
power of japan
i mean in front of us
and we went along asking who they were
and they were shaking
i'm talking about japan they ruled the
world then
they were shaking at meeting princess
anne is that amazing and so
one must be careful one must acknowledge
the power that the royal family have in
their their beartific power and their
sacred power uh
their bravery the effect they have on
the world yes more than any government
yes people
it translates
but what does the queen in particular
brian say about this country what are
the the values and virtues she
represents which i think are the great
in great britain in many ways but what
does she mean to you in terms of values
well i mean
why don't i i tend to go to shakespeare
all the time
king john is never done
and there's a character in it called the
bastard shakespeare's king john
and in the end the british forces are
retreating
uh and uh the delfa is going to invade
britain and there's king john and
there's the bastard who is the son of
kurdish a great hero and he says come
come come
to the emperor join me
uh
at last
um what am i going to say um
i i've um
the
ragers at our heels
but england's princes
have come home again
come the four corners of the world and
we shall shake them
england never shall sit
at the proud foot of a conqueror
i feel
the queen
is our mother
is sacred
omnipotent greatly loved by the creator
and this she displays
and she also employs a maximum effect
with a minimum of effort and that is
grace it is she has grace
and we must all pray for her and so
forth we are so damn lucky
to have such a unique
wonderful woman yeah
we are and i i
we need her and today we need him more
than ever she's got to go on we need her
she has and it's obviously she's having
a lot of problems with the health but
you'd expect that at her age and she's a
remarkable woman we wish you all the
very best i also wish your wife all the
very best brian it's lovely to see you
please send
all our best wishes
it's lovely to see you yeah sorry a
great day to be british it's nice to be
here it's a great day to be british i
think it's time to be proud of our
country that's right we're doing damn
well yeah we're bloody marvelous
i've been present to national parks for
seven years our parks are a great
success story
i'm sick of the criticism we're doing
marvelously i agree it's a time to
rejoice
and to rejoice in her health i agree
brian blessing great to see you thank
you very much